et parmi les pays européens les plus
impactés par ce regain épidémique la
russie alors que le nombre de cas
positifs atteint des niveaux inédits
dans le pays le maire de moscou a
assisté à l'inauguration d'une nouvelle
clinique plus de précisions sur place
avec notre correspondant tourne
clairement la situation sanitaire en
russie continue d'être délicate en effet
depuis de nombreuses semaines elle bat
des records de mortalité dû au co vite
ce jeudi pour la troisième journée
consécutive le record de décès
quotidiens a été battu avec ce nouveau
chiffre 1195 décès en 24 heures afin de
prendre en charge les patients atteints
la russie est la ville de moscou en
particulier se penche sur un traitement
qui semble porter ses fruits le don de
plasma
nous avons ouvert le plus grand centre
de russie pour la sélection de plasma
sanguin et en général quand nous
tournons au maximum de nos capacités
nous pouvons produire environ 10 tonnes
de plasma par mois ce qui permettra non
seulement d'en fournir aux malades mais
aussi de créer à partir du plasma des
immunoglobulines des médicaments
spéciaux qui renforcent l'immunité et
saufs des gens
la russie se trouve au beau milieu d'une
semaine chômé décrétée par les autorités
afin de mettre un coup d'arrêt à la
flambée épidémique
malgré les mauvais chiffres de la
vaccination et les records de mortalité
qui continuent d'être battu
la plupart des restrictions en vigueur
cette semaine devrait être levé à partir
de lundi